you and I and a friend of ours
yes mr. Ice Cube shot this video and in
like like a week it's done over 30
million that's crazy fuse we have a clip
for this thing we should wait a little
clip is that right let's just show the
little clip right now is a big mistake I
can't do this all day and you know I
can't walk five feet anywhere without
people saying I love it I love it it's
the second one we've done when I go out
with you guys something seems to happen
and that's just got me thinking movie we
got to do a movie
I want to say this on air I am a I'm a
fan okay I mean the fact that we came
back the second time and surpassed what
we did the first time is it's
unbelievable and it made me say what
you're thinking
I was already about to say a little sake
we need to do something together like
it's time so what I feel I feel like the
three of us should collab and I got the
perfect role but you didn't have time to
say collaborate you know no time for
that I'm true you didn't have time for
song and no time for the core racial
word okay go forward I got it laughs I'm
in on this project whatever it is
whatever it is good beauty tell me what
it is said the one thing that me and
cute kept talking about was like yo the
way that you wear your jeans they're
like so fitted they're so small like
whenever you walk it's like a it's like
petite like put together but it's like
something's mysterious about it and he
was like you could be streetwalker
number one street walker number one
[Applause]
we kept things the way you walk like you
get so much attention and all I'm doing
I'm pitching and being in the scene
serious scenes something's about to go
down and the only way I get distracted
is because you walk by and I'm like
something just went bad and it's not
it's not that went bad you just do me
off because you walk like this wait a
minute first of all no yes I dream was
it's the ride-along movie and it's like
it's you know it's three hard and it's
cube you know and then thrown it no you
watch streetwalker I'm not a male
prostitute I'm not I'm not saying you
are but in the movie you could be I want
to be in the car with you guys I have a
gun the equal status stuff you're and
you're mad cuz we didn't pay
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
bring the family you gotta walk up down
this street and I did not get to get
compensated and now I'm mad then you
pull out your gun I got guns at the end
but they're not loaded because you've
never had to use them because you're a
good street walk I mean that makes the
money okay let's do it it's not what
other people I mean look at the end of
the day it's about taking the first step
in the direction that you want to go in
and if you're serious about this
business you got to do this type of
stuff right just just call me booth I
[Laughter]
don't know how much you mess with him
[Applause]
with that
[Applause]
oh yeah that's the way I walk I have a
condition
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography